we look with surprise at the processes
unfolding in countries that
are used to considering themselves a flag, but my
progress, of course, those socio-cultural
upheavals that occur in the same
states and in Western Europe are not our business,
we don’t go there, someone in Western
countries is sure that you are aggressive
pestilence  whole pages of their own
history reverse discrimination of the
majority in the interests of minorities or the
demand to abandon the usual
understanding of such basic things as mom
dad family or even gender differences,
in their opinion, these are the things of the movement towards
social renewal of the adherent of the so
-called social progress, they
believe that they bring some kind of
the new consciousness is more correct than
before,
well, God forbid they have a flag in their hands, we are
talking ahead, but you know
what I want to say now
, the recipes they offer are
absolutely not for you, all this, how it
may seem unexpected to someone,
we have already passed in Russia  we were already here
in the Bolsheviks after  The revolutions of 1917,
relying on the dogma of Marxism,
Marx and Engels,
also announced that they would change the whole habitual
way of life, not only political and
economic, but also the very idea of
uman morality is on the basis
of a healthy existence of society, the destr
ction of the age-old values of the era of relations b
tween people, up to the complete rejection o
families, such was the
planting of encouraging denunciation of
loved ones, all this was declared a step of
progress, by the way, it
was widely supported in the world then and
was fashionable just like today the struggle
for equality against discrimination
turns into aggressive dogmatism on the
verge of absurdity when the great authors of the
past, the same Shakespeare, ceases to be
taught in  schools and universities
because they consider these ideas to
be backward classics declare them
backward who do not understand the importance of
gender or race in
Hollywood issues reminders of how and what
to make a movie about how many characters of
what color or  la there it must
be worse than the agitation and propaganda department of the
central committee of the
communist party of the soviet union to
counteract manifestations of racism, the deeds are
necessary and noble, however, in the new
culture of cancellation, it turns into
reverse discrimination, that is, racism, on the
contrary, obsessive emphasize it has grown its
id, emphasizing racial themes further
divides  of people,
after all, the dream of true fighters for
civil rights was just erasing the
difference refusal to separate people by
skin color, I remind you, I specifically asked my
colleagues yesterday to pick up this quote from
Martin Luther King, he said, as you
remember, I dream that the day will come
when my four children live here in
a country where they will be judged not by the
color of their skin, but in accordance with their
personal qualities,
this is the true value and
something is different, as we now
see what is happening by the way in
Russia, our citizens in the vast
majority do not care what color a
person has  skin he or she too  It’s not so
important that
each of us is a human
, that’s what is most important, a
perfect phantasmagoria has turned in a
number of Western countries, a discussion about the rights of
men and women, adherents of new approaches
go so far that they want to cancel,
note the concept of
those who risk saying that men and
women still exist and this
a biological fact almost
ostracizes parent number one parent
number two who gave birth parents who gave birth
place mother
prohibition of the use of the phrase
breast milk and its replacement with human
milk so that people are not sure of
their own gender are not
upset I repeat this is not new in the
twenties soviet
trigger cultures  the
so-called newspeak also invented the so-called newspeak, believing that in this
way they create a new consciousness and
change the value of the outfit, and I’m talking about simply
monstrous things when today’s children are taught from
childhood that a boy can easily
become a girl, and vice versa,
in fact, they actually impose on them the supposedly available
choice of
nav  The language removes this parents
forcing the child to make decisions
can break his life and no one
even consults with child
psychologists in general, a child at some
age is able to make a decision of
this kind or not
imposing things in their proper names, this is
simply on the verge of a crime against
humanity and everything is under  in the name and under the
banner of progress, well, someone likes it,
let them do it
when you already said that when shaping our
approaches we will be guided by the
ideology of healthy conservatism
it was several years ago then
passions in the international arena had not yet
reached the current intensity, although of course
it was already jumping clouds already then thickened
Now, when the world is going through a structural
breakdown, the value of reasonable conservatism
as the basis of a political course
has increased many times over precisely because of the
risks and dangers
that have survived and the fragility of the reality around us